hey everybody welcome back to this week
in startups it's our 900 episode and
I've instructed Emmy award-winning
producer Jackie that four episodes 900
through 1,000 I want 100 unicorn
founders on the podcast we're doing 100
straight unicorn founders she's having a
panic attack right now
I'm joking Jackie I never joke Justin
Kahn is with us today he is the serial
entrepreneur who you know from justin.tv
twitch and his new service atrium he's
had such an amazing time building
startup companies working with attorneys
that he decided to surround himself with
a hundred attorneys and build atrium
that was the plan that was the plan yeah
it wasn't painful enough to have to just
deal with legal bills constantly you
decided I'm gonna try to reinvent the
legal space oh you know I'm solving my
own problem that's what they always tell
you to do so I said okay I'm gonna I've
been a involuntary power user of legal
services my entire life unfortunately
and so I felt like I had a take where we
could figure out how to improve the
delivery service the technology the kind
of the whole package yeah all right
we're gonna get to that I want to get
this out of the way though this is the
fun part this is it five years
meandering yeah the company's investors
probably have lost a bit of faith people
think yeah this is kind of like what
they call a zombie startup it's going
sideways maybe even your girl felt that
way at the time definitely definitely
felt I want to tell everybody that I
felt every year that it was not going
anywhere
I just always happened during this
summer too because on the summer I would
log on Facebook and watch all these
people like posting their videos of them
doing barbecues and being happy and
going on vacation and I was like working
on in a darkroom on this you know
programming something yeah and I would
think why am i doing this why what is go
where is this going
and it never felt like we were making
progress I never felt like there was an
inflection where it was like oh my god
we figured it out yeah and so or maybe
we had days like that but then it
quickly refer to back to the baseline
right and now a hundred days of struggle
exactly and so I you know it was it was
that zombies start up feeling where we
were 25 people five years in had you
know weren't growing super fast and we
were like how where does this go
right we don't see an exit insight and
and you decide to call this meeting when
did you decide to call that meeting what
was that moment where you're just like I
need to shut this thing down and move on
or I just need to challenge everybody
with what was that the impetus for
deciding to sit everybody down to do
that brainstorming meeting alright I
this is a good one I don't think I've
actually told this story very publicly
before but basically Google came around
it was like we're interested in
acquiring justin.tv and it was a very
high price to be honest but they
basically long story short we talked to
them we talked to them what was a theory
their theory was you two bones basically
the entire via Internet on the video and
this is like Internet video and this is
one sliver small sliver layer yeah
exactly we might as well buy the feature
and they had YouTube live at the time
and so they came to us and you know
Justin TV was a decently sized site it
just wasn't very profitable and resin
like you know was a small company and so
we they they came to us and they wanted
to interview our entire team they
interviewed our entire team we let them
which you should never ever do never let
in them acquire ever interview your
entire team because they interviewed our
team and then they were like your team's
not good enough goodbye
Wow yeah which was like the most
demoralizing gut punch of 2010 or 2011
ever I think was 2010 thanks for letting
us come in we regret to inform you your
team sucks
exactly those people are smarter than
yours we would never elect you in them
you would be like significantly lowering
the bar for the people at Google basis
right we would never let you on campus
yeah like literally on a Sunday the
justin.tv like you have to work out of
the sales office except they're not good
enough to work there so we can't acquire
your company it's like how they treat
the it's like a contract contract
exactly it's like this is you could work
in the cafeteria but you have to work
for another company that we contract
with right yeah you'd be like the
cafeteria employees we're gonna contract
you or the customer support people we we
just don't want you to consider your
team Googlers yeah and like you can't
call your team Googlers and you have to
live in Fremont what what is it like to
go back to work with the team after this
happens what do you say to them when
you've been left at the altar just say
like eff google well yeah it wasn't
great um yeah
actually the team would like took it
very well which is very surprising so
that was the impetus we were like well
we can't get acquired and we're not
growing so we need to figure something
out huh and so we went to the drawing
board and we came up with these ideas
and that's when we had the meeting and
we started figuring it out was that the
Board of Directors who said like hey
guys you got to figure something out
here go one way or the other or was it
just you saw the end of the runway
coming and you just thought wow we're
gonna run out of money at some point we
saw the end of the runway coming I mean
we were actually we had hit
profitability so so actually the team
what happened was we had that
conversation then we were like [ __ ] we
need to get profitable we challenged the
team to get to profitability actually I
remember it was like 1 million in
revenue a month that's where we want to
get to and to me that was a gigantic
number that was infinity we would never
get I thought we would never get there
yeah and this was maybe at March of 2010
I think I remember one of our teammates
was like one of our team was asked what
happens when we get to a million a month
and I said hey we'll take everyone to
Hawaii for a week why
why not it's never gonna happen yeah and
literally six months later we hit it
because everybody came together to work
on getting to break-even and get into
that number Wow and so we hit it and
actually then that gave us a little bit
of breathing room then we had the
meeting I'm like okay how are we gonna
make this grow because that was all in
terms of like monetizing what we already
had got it and you went to you literally
went to Hawaii with the team we did it
was it was really fun I mean a lot of I
think a lot of early team members were
like that was the best week we ever had
all right I just flew on two planes so
that if one plane went down whatever
company would still be well there was a
lot of still the scalability and uptime
issues with our live video service so
there was all we had to like phase it